hi everyone i'm derek downey a developer
advocate at google i want to show you
how easy it is to get started developing
on cloud spanner google's highly
scalable relational database over the
course of several videos you will learn
how to set up your development
environment to work with spanner you
will see how to set up a spanner
instance and database as well as details
on defining your schema and finally you
will learn how to read and write your
data to spanner instances using standard
sql transactions and spanner mutations
in this first quick start video i will
connect a simple java application to the
cloud spanner emulator
the emulator allows you to mimic spanner
functionality on your local development
machine
this quick start will also highlight
creating the spanner schema as well as
reading and writing data into spanner
this won't be a typical hello world
application i'm going to build the start
of a simple banking app
this app will allow customers to create
an account and log in
i will use the jetbrains intellij ide
if you don't use intellij don't worry
you can still get started quickly using
your ide of choice so let's get to it
i will be connecting into cloud spanner
in this banking application
however since i'm just getting started i
want to use the cloud spanner emulator
which runs directly on my machine
the spanner emulator mimics the
functionality of a spanner instance
i can switch to a real spanner instance
later when this application is ready for
collaboration
so the first thing i need to do is
install the gcloud command line tool
there are instructions in the video
description of how to do this for your
operating system
but once gcloud is installed i will
create a new configuration for our
banking project
the project i specify doesn't have to be
a real google cloud projects since the
emulator won't validate it
but this is needed for our application
to use spanner's java library
alright now i will start the emulator as
a background task
once that is running i will create an
instance called banking
this uses the emulator configuration
since we are using the emulator
now we have our spanner instance running
but it doesn't do any good without a
database and schema
i could create this in the command line
but i want to make sure this step is
repeatable since i will eventually move
this to a real spanner instance
so i have created a file that has the
ddl commands to create the database and
my table
for now i am creating a single customers
table that stores some basic information
about the user including a username and
password for authentication
once i've provided the instance and
database configuration i can run the
file from my ide
great now i have the database defined
with a customers table
one neat thing is the ability to explore
the database directly within the ide
to do this in intellij i need to add the
cloud spanner data source from the
database tools
with that added i need to populate the
instance and project information
since i'm using the emulator i don't
need to authenticate to the instance
but i will need the url to connect to
the local host on port 9010 which is the
default for the emulator
i'll also pass in the auto config
emulator equals true parameter
perfect i can see my schema that i
created previously i'm almost done
to finish up i want to write some data
and then read it back
i'll need to be able to have users sign
up to my bank and i do that in my create
customer function
i am using standard sql within a read
write transaction to insert a user into
the customers table based on input
provided to the application
once a customer is signed up then they
will need to log in the login function
will issue a read from spanner to
validate the user's credentials
with the ability for customers to sign
up and log in i am ready to run the
application
i tell the application that i want to
sign up
and then i provide my information
once my customer is created i can log in
by providing username and password
and i've successfully logged in back in
my editor i can see the new user that
was entered from the application
fantastic it didn't take long to get my
simple application interacting with the
spanner emulator
this is great for getting my feet wet
with spanner but soon i will need other
developers to collaborate on this
application and for that i will need to
create an actual spanner instance
in the next video i will go over what a
spanner instance is and the different
options for creating one in the meantime
go ahead and try out the spanner
emulator for yourself and let us know in
the comments your experience
[Music]
you